i welcome everyone to brilliant minds
bold questions a virtual event series
exploring questions being addressed by
some of the world's top researchers
each talk pairs speakers and moderators
from across disciplines sectors and the
world to explore questions shaping our
future
if you are not familiar with us cfar is
a canadian-based global research
organization that convenes extraordinary
minds to address the most important
questions facing science and humanity
today's event is in partnership with the
cnrs the french national center for
scientific research a publicly funded
institution that supports research in
all scientific disciplines
my name is fiona cunningham and i'm a
director of research at seafarer and it
is my pleasure to introduce you to david
gossett and lenny diamante our speakers
today
david gossett is a cfar fellow in our
quantum information sciences program and
a professor at the university of
waterloo and the perimeter institute for
theoretical physics
he is a quantum computer scientist who's
interested in quantum algorithms and
complexity theory
lenny diamante is a research researcher
at cnrs the french national center for
scientific research and a professor at
the cerrone university in paris she is
also the vice director of the paris
center for quantum computing and
specializes in quantum cryptography
today we'll be we will be discussing how
quantum algorithms can be used to solve
emerging problems
so today's session will last about 30
minutes as host i will ask our speakers
questions and and they will also be
taking questions from you joining us
today throughout the session if you have
a question please submit it through the
q a function at the bottom of your
screen
lastly the session is being recorded and
will be available on the seafarer.ca
website next week
so thank you for joining us we really
appreciate your time and my first pick
off question is ver is very simple
what are quantum information
technologies
okay uh thank you for the nice
introduction fiona it's great to be here
with with all of you today
quantum
information technologies uh really
encompass a pretty broad set of
technologies that aim to harness the
physics of quantum mechanics to store
and process information
and one example of that which is my
research area is quantum computers and
in a quantum computer you would store
information in the sort of complex
quantum many body state
of a
physical system
and process the information using local
operations on subsystems of that state
but quantum technologies is a broader
term that also encompasses technologies
that can be used for communication for
cryptography for sensors
and and other uh information processing
tasks
and some of those are are the the sorts
of tasks that eleni is an expert in so
eleni maybe now is a good time for me to
let you jump in
thank you very much david and thank you
very much fiona um so it's a pleasure to
be here with all of you today so what
are quantum information technologies so
i guess i would that with respect to
what them david that just described for
me i i like seeing the quantum
information technologies as an outcome
of what has come to be known uh nowadays
is the second quantum revolution so then
obviously this leads the question what
is the first quantum revolution
so so the way we see it is that the
understanding of quantum mechanics um at
a bit of a macroscopic level has led in
the last decades and since many years
now um to the discovery of new
technologies that we're using in our
everyday life these examples include for
example the transistor
the hard disk lasers and mri so these
are technologies that are that are using
collectively in a sense microscopic
level quantum mechanics and and
constitute the output of the first
quantum revolution so quantum
information technologies has gone
further than that they actually go to
the control and manipulation of quantum
particles at the single particle level
and at the control between the
interaction between particles to produce
effects and encoding of information
information processing and communication
tasks that cannot be done
if you don't go at this level of
understanding of of um end of
manipulation of quantum objects and and
this leads exactly to a quantum
advantage and quantum effects in all
these categories of technologies that
that david just just mentioned
um
i guess one of the major application
areas where david works is quantum
information processing and quantum
computing so let's why don't we talk
about this a little bit further david do
you think you can tell us what is a
quantum computer and why is it different
in what sense is it different from a
classical computer
yeah great so um
maybe we can start by just thinking
about how we often learn about uh
computing in say a class at university
you might learn about storing
information in bit
and then processing information using
logical gates such as like the and or
the or gate
and you know because we often talk about
these things in that sort of abstract
level we often forget that at the end of
the day the device that you'll be using
to implement your
or gates or your and gates or whatever
it is your circuit your computation that
device lives in the physical world and
is constrained by physics and the fact
that we can you know build a computer
that has bits and implements logical
gates
is uh is because classical mechanics
you know the the physics that was used
to implement that device allows for you
to process information that way
and you know
what was realized by uh by famous
physicists richard feynman and david
deutsch around the same time in the
1980s
is that while the computers that they
had at that time and that we continue to
have today you know they've grown
increasingly powerful
uh those computers they they don't
actually exploit all of the physics that
we know
and quantum mechanics
you know incorporates effects beyond
classical mechanics such as
superposition and entanglement and the
really remarkable thing is that those
effects actually do provide an advantage
in computation for certain specific
tasks so what feynman and deutsch
proposed is the idea of building a
computer where the information is stored
using quantum devices processed using
quantum effects
and what we've come to understand is
that if you do things that way and you
build a computer in this manner
then there are tasks certain specific
tasks that you can solve faster than a
classical computer and it's not it's
crucially not just running every step of
a procedure to solve a problem faster
it's using a fundamentally different set
of transformations that allows you to
arrive at the solution uh using fewer
steps
okay that that makes sense so now um
this um how do does one go and i think
this is a crucial question i guess as we
move closer towards applications how
does one go from an abstract
understanding of quantum algorithm of
quantum computing to real world problems
so what of types of real world problems
that the quantum computer could really
solve efficiently
well that that is a great question and i
think that uh you know if i had the
perfect answer to that question
um i'd be maybe swimming in cash or
something like that so i think that um
uh
the way that our field has developed and
our understanding of the power of
quantum computers i mean it it really
was
in the 1980s as i mentioned feminine
deutsch proposed the idea of a quantum
computer and their
motivating example was
that quantum mechanics itself many body
quantum mechanics like for example what
you might see in quantum chemistry
those
types of simulations if you wanted to
simulate that on a classical machine
it would be uh you know we don't know of
a good algorithm for doing that
but on a quantum computer it would seem
that or they showed rather that
quantum simulation is a task that can be
performed uh much more rapidly than with
a quantum advantage on a quantum quantum
device
and then uh you know peter shore had
this major breakthrough in in the 1990s
that showed that certain number of
theoretic problems can be solved more
rapidly using quantum computers and
since then
you know we've also understood that
certain types of optimization problems
can be solved faster using
using certain types of subroutines so
at some level you know we're
for a long time we understood kind of
uh categories of problems where you know
certain subroutines could be deployed
where we get a quantum advantage but you
know you ask about real world problems i
think you know now is a time in our
field where devices are being built
and those questions are becoming more
pressing like how do we take you know
the idea of quantum simulation and the
abstract you know sort of quantum
advantage that we understand in some
kind of genera general setting and how
do we map that on to a problem that
matters for
you know a company or that matters for
you know all sorts of tasks that you
might imagine quantum simulation could
be useful for so for example people talk
about
using quantum simulation algorithms to
improve
um
you know to understand better batteries
or people talk about you know sort of
speculative ideas of how we might use
quantum stimulation uh in the real world
and i think
really understanding the details of how
that is going to work is is a major
challenge for our field and something
that involves bringing together subject
matter experts with quantum algorithms
experts
because most people who work in quantum
algorithms are not also experts say in
battery technologies or in
you know the types of quantum chemistry
that might be uh relevant for other
practical uh practical tasks
so i i don't have the perfect answer for
you but i think this is part of the
discovery that we're going to see over
the next
uh you know five or ten years is really
that matching of subject matter experts
with quantum algorithms experts and
trying to understand how we can take
these kind of like um
more abstract algorithms results and
apply them in the real world
it would be exciting
um so let me uh at that point let me
jump in and ask you a little bit about
the kinds of uh
quantum cryptography technologies that
you've been working on
so
in in particular what is cryptography
and why are researchers so interested
and if i can add in one more one more
aspect what are the potential
implications for current cryptograph
like classical cryptographic methods
once a quantum computer is built
good question so now we're shifting i
guess from from quantum computing and
quantum information processing to one of
the the next
um big application area of quantum
information technologies so that is very
um pertaining to cyber security and to
secure communications which is
particularly relevant i guess in our in
our society that is becoming more and
more digital and where very high risk
data are being are being transferred um
over uh over the internet so over um big
large networks um so what are the
cryptographic techniques that we're
using today so today we're relying on a
big number we're not going to go into
the details of all the techniques of
course that cryptography is using modern
cryptography is using today but the main
point behind all of these techniques is
that they do need to make some sort of
assumption about the computational power
of an adversary okay there we have to
assume that there is somewhere this is
what is common in cryptography a
malevolent party an adversary who wants
to
to eavesdrop to here to obtain
information that has been communicating
over over the information channel and
this uh this is dropper this malevolent
party we have to assume some uh
something uh in all modern cryptography
algorithms about their computational
resources okay so the point now is that
the some of the most common
cryptographic algorithms that we're
using today and are vulnerable to future
developments technological developments
it can come from a quantum computer like
the one that we're just discussing when
it will be become powerful enough to
break um to break such cryptographic
technologies it can come also for other
technological developments the point is
that once you make assumptions it means
that you have an internal vulnerability
so what quantum cryptography comes there
to offer is is filling up in this gap
and saying okay so because of quantum
mechanics we're going to operate our
cryptographic system not at the
mathematical level but at the physical
level we're going to come with a quantum
physics principle that we just mentioned
before superposition entanglement so the
main principles of quantum information
theory and and this protects um in in an
intrinsic way our communication so
essentially what's happening in quantum
cryptography is that any uh attempt of
malevolent party and adversary to
obtain information about the
communication that is being transferred
necessarily leads to errors detectable
errors and when
the legitimate parties of the
communication channel actually treat
them process this information and they
become detected this error and then uh
do everything that that is necessary to
bound this information okay to bound to
basically make it negligible to make
sure that they can produce a
cryptographic
sequence that that will be protected
that will that will be protected against
the against such
adversarial effects so the effect is
obvious i guess to answer your question
i guess this has an important
implications direct implications in
security uh communication because it
means at one level that uh that we're
offering a security guarantee a security
level that would not be available and
that would not be available in in
classical and classical
cryptography of course you know the
story is never easy if if the world
would be perfect there is a quantum
cryptography is not perfect either first
of all it cannot do everything so we
don't know how to do with chemical
cryptography authenticate itself so no
we're talking to the right person so
uh we also also has physical
requirements we can talk about it later
and some some limitations because we're
working at the physical level and not a
mathematical level one needs to pay a
lot of attention as well in practical
security once you go from an abstract
protocol to a real implementation um but
and and i think
but it does have an added a clear added
value in cyber security and the vision
today is that we have to to make hybrid
techniques exactly like in computing but
i believe and i'm sure you can confirm
this as well in david when i believe the
trend is that quantum processing
machines will probably be combined with
high performance computing and classical
machines in the same way in quantum
cryptography will not function alone it
needs to be hybridized and and bring a
very specific and well-defined added
value to to classical uh cryptographic
cryptography techniques so i think the
main challenge today is to make
classical and quantum cryptographies
work hand in hand to come with viable
solutions offering maximum security
right and uh if i can ask like can you
paint a picture of how
like how does a quantum cryptographic
protocol work i mean just in sort of in
layman's terms say
sure sure i can tell you um i can tell
you so essentially the the the point is
so i can mix a little bit of protocol
abstract description and a bit of
physical description okay so because i
am experimentals i feel comfortable
making making this link and so
maybe if it can help you can picture the
protocol thinking about physical objects
like the photons in our case okay photon
is the particle of light okay is the
fundamental particle of light and this
is the carrier of information for
quantum communication and cryptography
so in the hardware for quantum computing
has not been we don't know yet exactly
what will be the carrier of quantum
information it can be several there are
many candidates physical systems to be
called this but for quantum
communication and cryptography we know
it's light it's photos because light has
been transferred that can be transferred
nicely in over longer distances and and
it's less subject to noise so how would
the protocol work so you take your
photos you encoding video information on
them okay so the sender somehow in every
protocol it needs to what does it mean
in code information you basically take a
property of your quantum object um for a
photo it can be polarization okay the
way the waves okay
it translates doesn't matter really and
and and then we put on the photon this
zero and once okay the zero on once or
intermediate states the superposition
states are the fundamental basis of
quantum information and randomly so you
pick among these states um randomly okay
so randomness is an inherent property of
any quantum information protocol for
computing for communication and
everything then you send it over your
quantum channel which can be for example
an optical fiber or a satellite ring and
then the receiver um receives this uh
these quantum objects and then i can see
the receiver so you can you can be the
receiver exactly and so you you pick the
the correct measurement because the
correct measurement okay so this you can
also another another way of doing it is
to use entanglement the other properties
so you share and bangle photos between
these two parts and they both measure
these are equivalent ways of looking at
your protocol and then
from the measurement results there are
the two parties they correlate they
communicate they see what they have
measured what they have generated they
calculate they examine these results and
they see how much information and
potential each dropper could have
acquired out of this and essentially
because they can treat noise and any
noise can be attributed to adversary
they can somehow extract the secret
information that they were looking for
so this is in the in so any yeah so this
is the main the main idea behind that
behind these protocols
really but why don't we go back if you
have a little bit of time why don't we
go back a little bit to computing
and maybe you can tell us um what are
the recent developments in computing
what are near-term applications of
quantum algorithms what do you think the
main challenges in the field today yeah
that's a great question and you know i
think you really touched upon uh some of
these ideas earlier when you mentioned
the idea of like hybrid algorithms and
co-processing with classical computers
and you know i think
i think one of the
main questions is
how are we going to move towards
useful quantum algorithms
with near-term devices that are not
as far along as the kind of
model of computing that you might hope
to have in the future so for example in
the future we want to have large-scale
quantum computers that are capable of
correcting errors in the computation as
they occur
and those those quantum computers you
can really think of as like the analog
of um
you know or you should think of the
abstract model of like a set of quantum
bits and then a set of logical
operations and you could imagine writing
down on a sheet of paper a set of
transformations and then implementing it
on the quantum computer and there's not
really much difference between what is
actually implemented and what you wrote
down because
you know any uh any errors that occur in
the machine are corrected as as as the
computation proceeds and it really is a
sort of high fidelity implementation of
the thing that you wrote down the
algorithm you had in mind and that's
kind of the dream and that's uh the
technology is moving in that direction
but for now the kinds of devices that we
have and when you ask about near-term
devices what does that mean well it you
know john prescott coined the term noisy
intermediate scaled quantum
and
you know that reflects the fact that
these devices are noisy they don't
currently uh
they don't currently
have the capability of quantum error
correction um
their intermediate scale because they
have fewer qubits than
you know you might need to implement
shora's algorithm for example certainly
fewer than you would need to implement a
large scale version of shore's algorithm
but they are quantum and their quantum
in a sense you know not just in the
sense that there are quantum effects
going on but also
they're sort of computationally
interesting because we don't know how to
simulate these devices on a classical
machine
so there are beyond the range of what
can be done what can be simulated on
classical machine which means that at
some level there's some kind of quantum
advantage but we don't necessarily know
how to harness it in the presence of
noise and with few qubits and you know
small circuits that we can implement
and so people have tried to understand
uh algorithms that operate in this
regime but that has been much less well
studied than
uh you know the kinds of uh larger scale
algorithms that might be deployable in
the future and some of the ideas that
have been proposed are as you say like
hybrid quantum classical algorithms
variational quantum algorithms that have
a certain robustness to the types of
noise that might occur in these devices
but the the challenge there is that you
know when we talk about shore's
algorithm or some of these kind of
pioneering quantum algorithms that we
understand very well at least in theory
you know we have a an understanding of
what the run time of those algorithms is
what the performance guarantee what the
output of the algorithm will be
with a given input
but when you talk about designing
algorithms for near-term devices
oftentimes the algorithms that are
proposed are heuristic meaning that they
don't have performance guarantees
but they are something you could try on
a device if you had one
and so uh you know i think a lot of the
um
near-term applications have yet to be
really understood because you have to
run them on devices on of increasing
size to see whether or not there is
really an advantage they're not
necessarily algorithms that we can
analyze on a sheet of paper and say yes
we're going to get this much advantage
as long as we can build a device with
150 qubits it's really quite a bit more
challenging to understand those
algorithms because the analysis also
involves looking at the specific
hardware or the types of operation you
know the connectivity of your device and
certain other uh you know details of
your device that that you might not
necessarily have to care about if you're
building a large scale quantum computer
now are these the type of algorithms
you're working on or something like what
is your work well yeah so in a way yes
so my so i kind of alluded to the fact
that there's this kind of like
uh ephemeral boundary between uh what is
classically simulable
and what is beyond classical sort of
from a computational point of view so
you may have heard of
the google uh you know quantum advantage
demonstration where they sampled from a
probability distribution that is thought
to not be
you know possible to sample from in a
comparable amount of time using a
classical computer and so my my research
has uh you know tried to resolve or
delineate this boundary more sharply in
various
regimes so for example i study classical
simulation algorithms for quantum
computers the ways we can leverage
structure and quantum many body systems
to simulate them better on a classical
machine that can also classical
simulators can also be used to benchmark
small quantum computers so you know it's
not only useful to understand the
boundary but also to to uh to benchmark
these small small machines and on the
other hand you know i also study like
quantum advantage with restricted types
of quantum
computation so for example a short depth
quantity so the depth of a circuit is
like sort of the number of time steps uh
allowing for parallel a certain amount
of parallelism
and we we've studied things like um what
kind of quantum advantage can you
achieve with short depth quantum
circuits
great thank you for that that was a
really great tour of uh the current
state of quantum computing and quantum
cryptography
so we do have some questions from the
audience um
and
i'll just encourage
either of you who feels most equipped to
answer please please fire away
so this one is from
anuparam gauche and his question is so
people refer to
current classical computers as a touring
machine basically computation done by
these classical computers are modeled
designed by touring's abstract computing
machine does the quantum computer also
satisfy the turing machine model
that's a really great question and i
think you're really you've gotten to the
heart of why we're so excited about
quantum computers because you're right
that you know even though computers keep
getting better and better the computers
that we have our laptops our desktops
they're all from a
perspective of kind of what kind of
algorithms can they run they're all
equivalent to the turing machine model
proposed in the 1930s by alan turing
and the only model that we know of that
really is outside of the that cannot be
simulated by the turing machine model
efficiently is the quantum computer so
quantum computers are
are thought to be more powerful than
turing machines and they're the only
realistic model of computing that that
we believe has that property so thanks
for the great question
yeah thanks indeed um so and one last
one so how this is from chris ford so
how close are we to being able to apply
an algorithm such as shore's algorithm
beyond theoretical to factor a large
number and improve our performance gains
over a class classical algorithm
um
so eleni would you like to take i answer
this as an experiment please so we're
not uh so we're not there yet chris so
so i guess exactly like david was
discussing we're at the level where we
know how to do nisk devices noise
intermediate scale devices it means a
few hundreds of qubits in the best case
or roadmaps of big companies or startups
in quantum computing with based on
different technologies predict that they
should be able to get the two devices up
to a thousand cubits um within the next
three or four years but you need to
understand that implementing the
protocol like source algorithm requires
a massive number of of cubits much much
bigger number of qubits and why is this
true it's because for really
implementing algorithms like source
algorithm we need to be able to master
error correction and fault tolerance so
we need to be able to correct errors and
noise and which we know how to do we
have protocols to do it but they require
um a very big number of uh um redundancy
of essentially um the correspondence
between the physical qubits that makes
your device and the logical cubits that
are actually used for the computation is
not very favorable with the current the
codes we have error correcting codes and
fault tolerance algorithms so this so
there there is a need for theoretical
developments in this direction and and
and still milestones to be uh to be
reached from an experimental point of
view mastering noise uh for example in
sisters to be able to see implementation
of source algorithm i remain very
optimistic i think we'll see it one day
but it's very difficult to predict them
to predict today um without further
progress and exactly when this will
happen don't know if you agree david
this is my
absolutely
i have nothing to add it's a perfect
so i think i think that was a great
answer and it the the challenge of
quantum quantum computing its uses in
quantum cryptography is not lost on both
national governments with the unveiling
of huge huge swath of national quantum
strategies support to support scientific
research at the academic level it's very
exciting
um so thank you for that both of you i
genuinely appreciate your time um but
that is all the time that we have for
today so i'd like to thank all of you
for joining us and i'd especially like
to thank david and the lady for sharing
their insights with us
please do visit our website at cfar.ca
to find out more about this series and
to view recordings of previous talks the
recording of this talk will be posted
early next week thank you to both of our
speakers and to questions from the
audience and have a great rest of your
week
thank you thank you
[Music]
you